50 000 years ago a space Rock slammed
into Earth and made a big boom this
meteorite was only about 50 meters wide
but it weighed a whopping 300
000 tons
when it smashed down into the ground it
flattened everything in the vicinity
it left a crater so lunar-like that
astronauts trained there before landing
on the moon yeah this is meteor crater
in Arizona
and there have been many impacts like
this one in the long history of Earth
if this meteorite were to slam into New
York today it would destroy most of the
city the impact would leave a crater 1.3
kilometers wide but the fireball would
spread further everything within 1.7
kilometers of the Impact Zone would burn
even on the outskirts of New York City
the windows would shatter and many
people would perish
it would take years to recover from this
disaster
but this is nowhere close to the size of
some of the largest asteroid impacts
Earth has seen
some of them were so gigantic that if
they smashed into us today they would
cause our Extinction
most of these asteroids crashed when
Earth was very young
well at least in planetary years
some 2.2 billion years ago were pretty
big asteroid made its way down to Earth
where Australia is now
it left the oldest confirmed crater on
our planet
you're above a crater doesn't look like
much today but when it made its fatal
Landing
shook the planet quite a lot
you're a Bubba scarred the continent
with a crater 70 kilometers wide it
wiped out everything in its way with a
massive shock wave
scientists even think it helped end the
ice age that Earth was going through by
creating so much Vapor that it changed
the climate
now imagine this giant landing on Earth
today if it hit Australia again and left
a 70 kilometer crater there the fireball
would spread for 130 kilometers in all
directions
if it's set a course for New York it
would decimate the entire city
even on the outskirts everything would
be on fire and you'd get third degree
burns
but things could get so much worse if an
asteroid even larger than that hit us
like the one that crashed into Earth 1.8
billion years ago
this giant Comet punctured the ground
and shattered The Rock
it left a crater
130 kilometers wide where Canada is
today
we call this crater Sudbury Basin and
it's one of the largest asteroid impacts
Earth has seen in its history
1.8 billion years ago was a violent time
for our planet the atmosphere was
changing and continents were on the Move
shaking and rupturing the land on their
way
massive asteroid collisions were part of
a regular day back then
now if this Comet hit us today it would
be a total doomsday scenario
yeah if the Sudbury Basin impactor
landed on New York City today well there
wouldn't be in New York City it would
feel like being caught in an earthquake
that measured an 11 on the Richter scale
everything would be shaking from this
immense and Loud shock wave and
everything 300 kilometers from the
impact would instantly ignite
this is what the impact would look like
if it landed in France
yeah there's no chance you're surviving
this and we haven't even got to the
biggest impact yet
it's time for the dinosaur wiping
asteroid
65 million years ago an asteroid at
least 10 kilometers wide smashed into
Earth where Mexico is now and violently
ended the era of giant reptiles
now imagine that same impact today and
well yeah it would be incredibly violent
the asteroid would leave a crater
180 kilometers wide and the fireball
well the fireball would burn everything
in a 450 kilometer radius
if this asteroid hit New York its
effects would spread as far as Canada
and the impact would be would be so
painfully loud that it would deafen you
you wouldn't just hear it you'd feel
violent vibrations in your entire body
and if this big Space Rock doubled down
on Mexico well much of the country would
see the same fate the region saw when
the dinosaurs died
enormous shock waves would cause
widespread destruction hundreds of
kilometers beyond the impact site and
just like 65 million years ago the
impact would cause a massive tsunami
okay it's bad really bad but let's
finally get to our number one largest
impact in history
Q the vredafort asteroid the largest
almost the oldest and the most
terrifying space event on our planet's
record
two billion years ago a gigantic
asteroid slammed into where South Africa
is today it obliterated everything
it likely changed the earth's climate
and it most definitely killed whatever
lived here before the dinosaurs
this same impact today would bring
enormous death and destruction
this deadly Space Rock would obliterate
everything for hundreds of kilometers
the crater from the impactor would be as
wide as 300 kilometers and the fireball
would spread for 750 kilometers in all
directions
intense shock waves would rush across
the continent
add to this tsunamis earthquakes and
wildfires and this would be a horrifying
disaster nothing in the area could
survive this
but what's worse is that the disaster
wouldn't end there
all the debris dust and gases from the
impact would block the sunlight and
pollute the atmosphere we'd be like the
dinosaurs during their last days
temperatures would plummet the sudden
climate change would cause a massive
Extinction event
Earth would become a pretty Barren place
and Humanity might not be able to come
back from this
maybe it's best to Nuke an asteroid like
this before it ever reaches Earth
but that's a story
for another
[Music]